brought to you by assassin's creed unity
make history with friends available now
hey guys it is friday again which means
i get to fill you in on five of the
biggest things that happened in gaming
this week so you can get all clued in
let's get going
rocksteady believes in a future where
all platforms are equal since they're
hoping to have the same resolution and
frame rate for batman arkham knight
across all systems the 2015 release
which is being touted as the ultimate
batman simulator is still six months
away from going gold so nothing is set
in stone but rocksteady explains we
don't know what the resolution and the
frame rate's going to be yet that's
something that happens during the
optimization phase of the game we're
aiming for parity across all platforms
whatever it is it's going to be awesome
the legend of zelda majora's mask remake
for 3ds won't be your average remake
according to nintendo series producer eg
enuma has said that the project has been
in development ever since they finished
developing ocarina of time 3d in 2011
and is more ambitious than we might
expect he said they didn't want to
announce the title until they could
assure gamers that the remake will be
worth their time details on specific
changes and additional features will be
revealed at a later date but enuma
assured us that the gameplay experience
would be smoother than the original
without sacrificing the look and feel of
the creepy game world
ubisoft seemed to be taking the plethora
of issues with assassin's creed unity to
heart by saying they're changing company
policies as a result said policies
include offering customers open betas or
early access so they know what they're
getting into like what they've done with
the crew and changing the way the
company works with reviewers ac unity
caused a stir this week since the
embargo for its reviews would only be
lifted 12 hours after the game was
released to the public ubisoft have
implied that online focused games are
difficult to review prior to release
since the worlds are yet to be populated
meanwhile the company are also still
apologizing for assassin's creed unity's
myriad of technical problems and are
pledging to deploy fixes
as for more zeldary things nintendo have
said that the upcoming open world zelda
game looks even better than it did when
we got our first glimpse of it at e3
series producer and dude from two
stories ago eg
told japanese games publication for
mitsu that nintendo considered a bunch
of different looks for the game before
deciding on the unique art style we saw
in the announcement trailer onuma also
spoke about the towering spider-esque
monster from the trailer which has never
appeared in the series before saying he
wanted players to have a think about how
to defeat it as opposed to knowing
exactly how to defeat an octorok by
deflecting its rocks with your shield
because that's what you do in every
zelda game ever made personally for
spiders i find a rolled up magazine or a
piece of paper slipped under a glass
rarely goes awry or just shoot for the
big glowing bit
microsoft have said the xbox one is
surging ahead by outselling the ps4 for
the last two weeks in the us microsoft
have suggested that thanks to
blockbuster game releases new bundles
and their 50 price cut the xbox one has
seen a massive upswing in sales
microsoft exec youssef mehdi confirmed
the news adding that they are almost at
the point of selling more than 10
million consults to retailers by
comparison sony has sold more than 14.5
million ps4s in its lifetime according
to most recent figures
as your question of the day let me know
what zelda enemies you'd like to see
return in the upcoming wii u game and
what gaming news you cared about this
week this week on site i cover how to
keep a long running series fresh on the
gist skyrim mob talks 10 essential mods
for your game and in two minutes covers
the entire historical and ludicrous
assassin's creed narrative that is all i
have for you this week as always thanks
for hanging out be sure to hit that
subscribe button if you haven't already
and i'll see you on monday